ce débat de ce club maintenant consacrée
à la question de l'immigration nous
irons dans du côté de calais dans
quelques instants on ira également à
briançon des migrants ont occupé à la
gare il y à quelques heures mais d'abord
pour poser le débat on va regarder
ensemble les grands chiffres de
l'immigration résumé par gaspard flammes
en france et en 2020 le pays compte 6,8
millions d'immigrés ce qui représente
10% de la population totale si l'on
regarde leur continent de naissance 47 %
viennent d'afrique 32% d'europe 14%
d'asier et 6 % d'amérique et d'océanie
concernant le nombre de visas la france
on a délivré 710/1000 en 2020 contre
trois millions cinq cent mille en 2019
une baisse de 80 % qui s'explique par la
crise du coc vite 19 et la fermeture de
nombreuses frontières enfin toujours sur
la dernière année la nationalité
française a été accordée à 85 mille
personnes un chiffre en baisse
permanente depuis cinq ans sur les
questions d'immigration la france hier
la vis depuis fin septembre le nombre de
visas accordés aux personnes originaires
d'algérie du maroc et de tunisie a été
divisé par deux et cette thématique à
six mois de l'élection présidentielle
prend de l'ampleur une thématique qui
prend de l'ampleur et on va en parler
question peut-être un peu direct pour
commencer 20 membres elle est ce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un problème en
france avec les migrations tout cas
c'est une question électorale qui est
très très importante aujourd'hui pour
toute une partie électorale les enquêtes
sont pas forcément raccord avec
plusieurs enquêtes qui montrait que
c'était plutôt la quatrième ou le
cinquième préoccupations des français la
dernière enquête fondapol dont se fait
aujourd'hui échos le figaro et bien
montre que c'est quelque chose peut-être
de plus prégnant c'est quelque chose qui
est très situerez d'un point de vue
électoral hausse modo électorat de
droite doit plus d'importance que
l'électorat de gauche donc c'est quand
même un élément qui aujourd'hui est
assez central et qui en réalité renvoie
à tout un tas d'autres problématiques
parce que derrière la problématique
immigration vous avez des problématiques
économiques l'immigration économique
chômage et cetera aides sociales ce qui
aujourd'hui fait une partie du discours
zemmour et vous avez une problématique
évidemment identitaire donc c'est un
sujet à tiroirs et c'est un sujet
aujourd'hui qui faute d'avoir été pris
en compte de manière réellement sérieuse
par toute une partie de la classe
politique est en train de revenir en
boomerang l'immigration ce n'est pas une
entité ya plusieurs problématiques sous
ce terme au moins deux que ne distingue
pas suffisamment me semble-t-il les le
personnel politique quand j'écoute ce
notamment madame pécresse qui nous
parlent de quotas parce que vous avez
l'émigration légale c'est à
l'immigration
autorisé avec des titulaires de visas
les titulaires de permis de séjour qui
elle après on peut discuter si on a trop
ou pas assez var après tout
c'est passé pas un sujet
infamant et mais ce qui me pose ce qui
pose particulièrement problème à mon
avis est là où l'état est débordé
c'est sur l'immigration clandestine
il est là un sujet c'est le vrai sujet
et là vous fassiez des quotas ou pas de
quotas les clandestins et se moque de
vos quotas alors le sujet de
l'immigration clandestine c'est sujet
numéro un avec avec alan là comme le
disait vous disiez tout à l'heure des
des tiroirs à l'envi de au moins c'est
que souvent s'être immigration
clandestine avec des gens qui viennent
en france pour demander des visas et
bien qui leur sont refusés qui sont
déboutés là qu'est ce qu'on fait deux
puisqu'on n'arrive pas à les renvoyer et
aller à faire en sorte que ils
reviennent dans leur pays parce que leur
pays d'accueil de départ ne les accepte
pas parce que on a des moyens qui sont
peut-être un peu défaillant
parce qu'on a des accords avec ces pays
là qui sont pas complètement solide ça
c'est la première des choses est la
deuxième des choses c'est qu'à mon avis
et c'est ce sujet qui
arrive à vicier le débat politique en
france et qui fait dire à certains
n'importe quoi qui fait dire à d'autres
enfin qui fait dire à certains surtout
n'importe quoi que ce soit dans le
laxisme ou dans la répression à outrance
et ce qu'il faut dire aussi c'est ça que
je voulais ajouter c'est que tous très
souvent ces gens viennent de pays qui ne
sont pas des pays en guerre ni des pays
où règne une dictature
politique
mortifère et intérêts ce sont des pays
il faut le savoir sont souvent des pays
d'afrique de l'ouest je dis pas où il
fait bon vivre parce que souvent ce sont
les pays qui sont atteints par la
pauvreté par le réchauffement climatique
et par d'autres choses mais ça n'a rien
à voir avec l'afghanistan le mali ou
ou d'autres pays où la corée du nord
avant de parler des propositions des
candidats voir l'illustration de cette
problématique dans le pas de calais à
côté de calais à merlimont exactement
qui est devenu comme d'autres petites
communes un point de départ vers
l'angleterre pour de nombreux migrants
les réseaux de passeurs tente désormais
d'échapper aux contrôles en se
dispersant sur tout le territoire et
cela complique le travail de tous les
acteurs locaux on regarde ce reportage
dugo lemonnier de marion vigreux c'est
depuis cette plage que se font les
passage vers l'angleterre qui est tout
juste à 40 km depuis quelques années les
départs ne se limite plus à la région de
calais mais s'étendent sur toute la côte
d'opale jusque dans la baie de somme un
nouveau défi pour les forces de l'ordre
de jour comme de nuit ces gendarmes
appuyés par des réservistes pas trop le
long du littoral et notamment dans cette
réserve naturelle de 1000 hectares fait
de dunes et de forêts ou les migrants se
dissimule avant de gagner la plage toute
cette zone au fond là bas c'est la zone
d'attenté viennent d'abord ils
s'abritent se repose il s'alimente parce
qu'ils sont très fatigués il ya des
femmes des enfants et des nourrissons
parfois et ensuite dès que les passeurs
sont là que le matériel est là ils vont
traverser toute cette zone
toute cette zone qui est là devant nous
et vont arriver à la mer sur le chemin
on devine encore les traces de leur
passage toujours avant de prendre la mer
il se déleste de leurs vêtements
pour être le plus léger possible pour
monter dans le bateau ici pas de camp
les migrants sont en transit ils
viennent uniquement pour tenter la
traversée depuis cet été la pression
migratoire s'est accentuée et des
tentatives de passage ont atteint un
niveau record
les gendarmes ont pour mission de les
empêcher cette année 860 traversées ont
été interceptés sur le département les
passeurs met à disposition des étrangers
en situation irrégulière des
embarcations de fortune qui sont
principalement des zodiac mais qui sont
largement sous gonflés ou sous motorisé
et ce qui implique donc une prise de
risque énorme en fait pour ces
populations l'idée de manoeuvre c'est
d'empêcher le départ donc
en s'interposant
physiquement entre le littoral et la
mère de manière à intercepter un
l'embarcation et si malgré tout
l'embarcation parvient à rejoindre
à rejoindre la mer ces deux déclenchées
au plus vite mais secours ce qui
complique le travail des gendarmes c'est
le terrain très vaste à couvrir et les
réseaux de passeurs très organisés pour
lutter contre ce trafic l'angleterre
veut durcir ses conditions d'accueil
quand la france lui demande plus de
moyens financiers mais ici cette
politique de contrôle ne fait pas
l'unanimité pour la maire de merlimont
qui voit passer ces migrants il faut
réfléchir autrement pour l'instant on
essaie de contenir l'incontournable
je le pense réellement on dépense de
l'argent inutilement et en plus on fait
le jeu des criminels
parce qu'il ya une économie souterraine
qui est en train de d'émerger qui
rapporte peut être aujourd'hui encore
plus d'argent le trafic d'os médecin
remporte peut-être encore plus d'argent
que le trafic de drogue
et ça c'est pas entendable un moment
donné faudrait quand même remettre
l'humanité au coeur de la discussion
même discours du côté des associations
céline et pierre sont membres du
collectif c'est nous qui accueille des
migrants à domicile
ce qu'ils demandent c'est une vraie
politique d'intégration
ici se créer les conditions d'un piège
où on a l'impression que par rapport à
leur désir de traverser
rien n'était fait pour comprendre pour
les accueillir la piste de l'intégration
est une piste très intéressante et qui
doit être privilégié parce que de
l'expérience qu'on a pu avoir au sein de
l'association toutes les personnes qui
ont été accueillies ont trouvé un emploi
se sont intégrés et ça se passe bien
selon les autorités britanniques cette
année seize mille migrants sont parvenus
à rejoindre leurs côtes voilà et on vend
dans ce reportage dans le pas de calais
1 du côté de calais de toute sa région
évidemment la question se pose toujours
cinq ans après le démantèlement de la
jungle de calais la frontière la
question de la frontière elle est
toujours dans l'impasse finalement la
question de la frontière est toujours
dans l'impasse et comme vous l'avez dit
ça fait des années que ça dure et en
réalité cette question de calais et plus
largement de l'immigration illégale est
un vrai problème pour le politique parce
que ça montre l'importance du politique
tout à l'heure vous parliez notamment de
la question de l'immigration illégale et
du fait que en effet on ne pouvait pas
renvoyé beaucoup de ces clandestins
c'est le vrai problème vous pouvez
toujours dire je vais faire une nouvelle
loi sur l'immigration
on en a 1 moyenne trois ou quatre par
quinquennat et au bout du compte cette
loi ne règle rien parce qu'elle peut
régler les micra l'immigration légale
elle peut monter des sanctions excepté
en matière d'immigration illégale mais
qu'est ce que ça change quand vous avez
des obligations de quitter le territoire
qui ne peuvent pas être mis en
application
soit parce que vous ne savez pas
exactement d'où viennent les gens qui
brûlent leurs papiers soit parce que les
pays d'accueil ne veulent pas les
reprendre s'impliquent un bras de fer
diplomatique sur lequel on n'a pas
toujours les moyens parce qu'on est des
péons nez avec des pays qui avec qui on
a d'autres intérêts contre le terrorisme
et cetera donc du coup ça rend le bras
de fer diplomatique extrêmement
compliqué et vous montrer au bout du
compte une forme d'impuissance du
politique a visiblement passé tout à
l'heure un peu à la surenchère en
matière de propositions sur
l'immigration mais en réalité vous avez
là l'une des sourds de cette source de
cette surenchère si jamais je propose
une nouvelle loi aujourd'hui bain
le lectorat ne me croient plus alors je
propose de la faire passer par
référendum ça va pas changer grand chose
parce que conventionnellement c'est
compliqué et donc du coup comme je sais
que ça ne va pas changer grand-chose
propose de remettre en cause la primauté
du droit européen donc là vous avez une
surenchère qui en fait est le symptôme
de cet impôt très on va parler de sept
chercheurs mais pour rester sur ce qui
se passe du côté de calais on a attendu
dans le reportage on essaye de contenir
l'incontournable il ya juste pour rester
dans l'actualité gérald darmanin et hier
il a envoyé un médiateur puisqu'il ya
des personnes qui sont en grève de la
faim en soutien aux migrants ils
envoyaient le médiateur le directeur
général de l'office français de
l'immigration mais au-delà de ce qui se
passe en france ça pose aussi la
question des relations
franco-britanniques cette question de
l'immigration et on voit que ça ça son
antre et la france parce qu'en fait ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'il ya les
accords du touquet c'est au terme des
accords du touquet qu'il a été décidé
que la frontière entre
la grande bretagne et nous serait situé
en france et le problème c'est que vous
avez la jungle de calais et toute cette
immigration l'acquis et côtières c'est
une immigration ce sont des gens qui
veulent aller en grande bretagne
précisément qui viennent beaucoup de
2-2-2 ganis temps qui viennent de deux
pays du caucase enfin delà de la zone du
caucase et ils allaient dans un cul de
sac parce que bach nous on les empêche
de passer en angleterre
et pour les empêcher de passer en
angleterre on demande l'aide des anglais
comme ça se passe chez nous alors
normalement il doit nous donner de
l'argent pour eux c'est très compliqué
c'est si metz que c'est pas bien
appliquées depuis le break site est
peut-être depuis quelques jours ça sonne
il veut créer
les traverses et de l'avant bien sûr
c'est et alors il ya une reprise
effectivement des traversées avec un
nombre de morts important depuis depuis
pas mal de mois donc
c'est un sujet qui doit être bien
évidemment sur la table sachant que même
avant
le brésil tu les britanniques
n'appartenait pas n'était pas dans les
accords de schengen donc de très bien je
sais pas comment résoudre ce sujet
le maire de briançon au dessus j'ai
évidemment enfin reste évidemment grand
thème de l'immigration mais on va
quitter calais on va aller du côté de
briançon bonjour monsieur le maire
arnaud murgia merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous ce matin on en parlait hier dans
notre dans notre émission déjà il ya
environ 200 migrants qui ont occupé
votre regard la garde de briançon que
s'est il passé on en est où ce matin
alors la situation est réglée puisque
nous avons réussi à évacuer tout le
monde dans le calme avec des moyens des
bus qui ont été mis à disposition et
tout s'est finalement plutôt pas trop
mal terminée et je crois dans un cadre
dans un cadre acceptable et malgré tout
avec avec fermeté mais effectivement on
vit depuis quelques jours maintenant un
afflux particulièrement important de
migrants venant principalement
d'afghanistan
c'est à peu près de l'ordre de 100 à 150
par personne par jour qui passe de
manière irrégulière la frontière on
pensait à peu près que 45 50 jours après
les événements de kaboul ont honoré
cette impasse ce fruit très fort
effectivement nous l'avons et c'est
l'équivalent à peu près de 5% de la
population de ma ville qui a passé et
régulièrement la frontière dans les
quatre ou cinq derniers jours donc oui
c'est un sujet extrêmement difficile il
ya une réaction de l'état qui est forte
le ministre de l'intérieur a fait son
travail de manière extrêmement réactive
et je l'en remercie mais effectivement
on a un sujet pour les prochaines
semaines qui va être très très fort à
nos frontières et à la frontière franco
italienne en l'occurrence à la frontière
franco italienne
damman et vous dites l'état était
suffisamment à vos côtés vous êtes
suffisamment soutenu
oui parce qu'on a vécu cette situation
extrêmement difficile on s'est retrouvé
avec un afflux de 200 300 personnes en
vie le ministre l'intérieur a
immédiatement décidé d'envoyer en
renfort deux escadrons de gendarmerie
mobile pour que la frontière soit tenue
et et mieux tenues maintenant le ça pose
des sujets de fond il faut se le dire le
premier sujet de fond c'est du mbba est
ce qu'on est capable de faire respecter
nos frontières et je le crois il ya un
deuxième sujet j'ai écouté le débat que
vous aviez tout à l'heure à mon avis le
vrai sujet des prochains mois et en
l'occurrence de la présidence française
de l'union européenne c'est frontex on a
aujourd'hui un vrai de vrai sujet là
dessus parce qu'on voit bien que au
niveau de nos frontières leurs six plus
est chez moi en altitude avec des cols
avec des sentiers de randonnée qui sont
utilisées par des passages en freiner ce
phénomène depuis maintenant cinq à six
ans alors avant c'était une immigration
principalement économiques qui venaient
d'afrique subsaharienne là on voit un
impact très claire de la situation en
afghanistan est effectivement il va
falloir que nous nous posions
collectivement la question de la
capacité à le résoudre et on va
évidemment parler en plateau merci merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
pour nous parler de la situation dans
votre vis du côté de briançon situation
réglée vous nous l'avait dit ce matin
est justement dray on va avoir avec vous
évidemment on en parlait et monsieur le
maire le disais c'est un sujet
dont cent pas
oui et il y en un qui est toujours pas
candidat mais qui impose déjà ses idées
dans le débat public eric zemmour qui a
une proposition radicale arrêter toute
immigration légale et illégale alors
c'est difficilement applicable mais sa
force les candidats déclarés à se
positionner voire à se droitiser michel
barnier lui veut un coup d'arrêt c'est
l'une des propositions choc de son
programme avec un moratoire de 3 à 5 ans
sur l'immigration l'idée c'est d'imposer
ce temps d'arrêt pour vérifier
l'efficacité des procédures dresser un
état des lieux des flux migratoires en
france et voir éventuellement les liens
avec les autres pays européens il
propose aussi un référendum sur
l'immigration ce n'est pas la plus
originale des idées parce qu'elle est
très prisé un eric ciotti aussi en veut
un xavier bertrand valérie pécresse
marine le pen aussi veut consulter les
français sur la question la candidate du
rassemblement national propose même de
toucher au premier article de notre
constitution pour y inscrire la maîtrise
de l'immigration la priorité nationale
aussi dans l'axé par exemple au logement
ou à l'emploi eric ciotti et valérie
pécresse voudrait quant à eux une
réforme pour inscrire cette fois ci dans
la constitution un quotas d'immigrés
accueillis en france chaque année alors
pour l'instant ce sont deux cent
quarante cinq mille titres de séjour qui
sont accordés en france chaque année et
audrey quand on était à gauche alors à
gauche les candidats ont un peu de mal à
se faire entendre l'écologiste yannick
jadot et anne hidalgo s'accordent
néanmoins pour un meilleur accueil des
immigrés en respectant les
responsabilités de la france la
situation à calais comme on l'a vu tout
à l'heure et inacceptable pour la maire
de paris et jean luc mélenchon vente la
créolisation de la société il n'a pas
forcément de mesures concrètes pour
l'instant et puis je termine par
emmanuel macron alors il pas encore
candidat mais il a récemment réduit de
moitié le nombre de visas accordés aux
algériens ou marocains c'était une
décision inédite peut-être pour exister
dans ce débat qui monopolise le début de
la campagne ouais effectivement sa main
n'a pas lésiné début de la campagne est
ce qu'on est dans une forme de
surenchère on vient d'entendre le résumé
des propositions fait par audrey ou est
ce que finalement on est dans les
réponses qu'attendent les français on
est probablement dans une forme de
surenchère au moins pour ce qui est de
la droite pour emmanuel macron l'idée
c'est de rentrer dans un bras de fer
avec les pays qui sont émetteurs de
clandestins ou en tout cas qui sont
censés les contrôles à leurs frontières
donc là on est dans une politique mais
qui souvent est bien une relative et de
relative court terme sur la droite vous
avez en effet une course à l'échalote je
prends l'exemple du référendum pour
faire un référendum il faut savoir que
l'article 11 a priori ne concerne pas le
l'immigration donc il faudrait d'abord
modifier la constitution pour ensuite
pouvoir faire le référendum la prochaine
fois que vous aurez gérard larcher sur
votre plateau je vous invite ça
peut-être mais le mettre un petit peu
mal à l'aise à lui demandé ce que ferait
le sénat si jamais on ouvrait on
étendait le champ de l'article 11 de
toute façon ce serait une affaire de 2 3
ans pour modifier la constitution et
ensuite faire votre effet un dunk ratera
pas dans l'immédiat comme elles
promettent ses candidats et ensuite vous
mettez quoi moi encore une fois je veux
bien c'est à dire que votre loi même
prise par référendum ça reste une loi
est en effet elle peut permettre de
mieux réguler l'immigration immigration
légale mais sur l'immigration illégale
ça va pas changer grand chose par
ailleurs loin même pas référendum ça
reste une oie donc soumis au droit
européen et en matière d'immigration le
droit européen notamment le droit de la
convention européenne des droits de
l'homme si on prend par exemple la
question du regroupement familial est
assez bavard en tout cas la
jurisprudence donc votre loi face aux
traités européens devant juge qu'est ce
que fait le juge il écarte la loi il
fait primer le traité et au bout du
compte vous retrouvez avec une jolie
lois votées par référendum pour laquelle
vous avez modifié la constitution mais
qui sert à rien alors on se retrouvait
avec la question du droit européen
encore bah oui oui bien sûr c'est pour
ça que monsieur le maire a parlé de
frontex frontex ces dispositifs qui est
installé à la sortie fin aux frontières
de l'union et c'est là le patron de
frontex qui est un français a déploré
plusieurs reprises son manque de moyens
c'est là qu'il faut effectivement mettre
des moyens et puis je pense que ça sert
à rien de légiférer dans tous les sens
en france appliquons déjà le la loi et
donnant des moyens à ceux qui sont
chargés la faire respecter et peut-être
que déjà ça il y aura des améliorations
à constater ça me paraît
ça me paraît de bon sens et on en
débattra effectivement de ddd nous monde
bras pour rien
[Musique]